we're going to begin this hour with a
Missouri man who spent 28 years in
prison for murder he did not commit in
1994 Lamar Johnson was arrested for the
killing of his friend Marcus Boyd he
spent nearly three decades in prison
after a witness picked him out of a
police lineup That witness his name was
Greg elking says that he was pressured
by law enforcement to identify Johnson
as one of the two men who killed Mr Boyd
in February after decades-long fight to
prove his innocence Johnson's murder
conviction was finally overturned by a
judge in St Louis
the motion of the circuit attorney up to
22nd Judicial Circuit filed herein for
the benefit of Lamar Johnson is granted
[Applause]
the conviction of Lamar Johnson and
Steve Lamar Johnson calls 22
941-37068 is here by set aside and held
for not
we are so happy and so honored to tell
you that Lamar joins us in the studio
Lamar we're so glad to hear have you
here Aaron Moriarty's kept us up to date
we followed your story for many years
I'm so glad to meet you in person take
us to that moment for a second what was
going through your mind when you heard
those words uh relief yes I felt like 28
years of the struggle was finally being
lifted and so that's why you can see me
just kind of yes it did seem like a
thank you Jesus moment what's been the
biggest adjustment for you since you've
been out what's been the hardest or the
most difficult technology technology how
so that did not exist when I was out
there when I left there was pages and I
have cell phones and you can Siri all
you have to do is ask her yes is that an
Apple Watch you have there yeah uh I
didn't think that I would want all this
stuff but then I find that it's useful
and what about living your life day to
day the choices you make or the options
does that ever seem overwhelming to you
it is like like when you're inside you
you know you get what you get right on
Mondays you're going to have hamburgers
on Wednesday you have such and such so I
find myself when I go to restaurants and
I have this long list it's like kind of
hard to
that you get to decide this side yeah
all the stuff we take for granted same
way when in convenience stores you go in
and you see everything just on these
shelves and there's 10 different types
of razors yeah yeah you got to walk uh
your daughter Kira down the Ohio that
was a blessing what was yet take me
through that emotion how you felt on
that day here's a picture of the two of
you uh what was going through your mind
how did you feel how old was Kira when
you went that's what I was going to say
she was just five months when I left so
then when then I had to see this
beautiful woman it was grown and making
the decision to start a life with
someone else and so I was just grateful
to be able to be there and and walk her
down the house so key to your wrongful
conviction was the testimony of one
individual in particular a Greg elking
who are Aaron Moriarty actually
interviewed I want to play that a little
bit from that interview and then and
then talk about it can we roll that
you had doubts right afterwards why
didn't you tell somebody why didn't you
say nobody talks to me nobody who am I
going to tell them I don't know who I
could have told did it occur to you at
that moment that you might have put an
innocent man yes Behind Bars without a
doubt because I lied on the testimony I
lied because I thought I was doing the
right thing
so Lamar you may not have been able to
hear because you don't have the earpiece
in but uh that was elking saying he felt
pressured to identify you and that he
had he knew in the moment that he lied
what's it like knowing that was his
perspective in this pivotal moment that
changed your life forever and years you
can never get back well yeah I mean I
can understand the pressure that he was
under and but I try to look more at the
end as opposed to the beginning and I'm
grateful that he not only acknowledged
that he made a mistake but he actually
took steps to try and to change it and
actually he did and so uh that's that's
the part that I focus on I'm glad he did
that too but around year five year ten
yeah maybe couldn't you have had a
little moment with yourself Mr elking
Right I mean that doesn't he did come
forth yours yours earlier at least
around 2003 and it was just uh
unfortunately the way the system works
that prevented it from actually being
him actually being able to be heard what
was so fascinating to me and so
frustrating about your case was even the
prosecutors were saying he needs to come
out and that didn't change for a while
so how did you process process that
knowing that they were saying you
shouldn't be here and yet there you said
you seem to have no bitterness maybe
maybe you've been through all of that no
you're not angry you're not bitter no
because uh if you hold on to the anger
you're just imprisoning yourself again
and so I did 28 years I'm not going to
do this the rest of my life being bitter
about
the past it's easier said than done you
have an amazing lightness of being here
as you sit before us and people always
play the game you know what would you do
if you were wrongly you talk about it
you know you have a conversation you
imagine if I were Lamar Johnson how
would I get through those 28 years how
did you get through them I know where
you are now but how did you survive
those years well when I knew the truth
and so I knew this something had to have
gone wrong and so I focused on how can I
find out what went wrong and so I went
to the library I learned as much as I
could about the law I learned as much as
I could about getting documents and
things like that and then I did
practical things like running working
out that to keep your mental health to
keep yourself sane but you know you
receive no compensation from the state
of Missouri when you were released so
how do you even begin to build your life
what do you do for a living how do you
get a job how do you come back in
society well unfortunately I had the
Innocence Project and I had a good
friend of mine named Ricky kid who's
kind of helped me he was here right now
yeah and he's an exonary too we I met
him inside we made a pact that whoever
got out first and was going to come back
and help each other he got out so and he
and he he did he kept that right he kept
that promise and you said and you're
talking about the Midwest Innocence
Project you want to help others in
similar situations prevent it from ever
getting to where absolutely I think
there's a purpose and pain and I think
that uh the reason why we go through
things is so that we can either help
people avoid going through the same
troubles or to help them get through it
and so that's what I feel like an
obligation you and Ricky are still very
tight you know you could say you all are
doing life you actually are here we're
actually doing that's what Ricky told me
in the green room I thought that was so
good I was going to claim it as my own
but it was Ricky who said I think that's
very well said yes it's so good to have
you both here we are cheering you on
cheering you on Lamar Johnson Tony's
right you do have a light I need some of
that light sometimes thank you very much